have you guys seen her she hasn't popped
yet what that damn it
she was supposed to come out yesterday I
decided to give baby Halbert a newspaper
from the day she was born
set me back 55 bones
but she decided to take her sweet time
so now I have to switch it with today's
paper
Indian guys always wear their cell
phones outside their pants it's so dorky
oh no no that's not dorky look it's
easily accessible boom like this 9-1-1
hello Scranton stranglers in the house
inside the house
put it in your pocket
stop too late if that was the real
Scranton Strangler you'd be so strangled
by now
if you're out there a Strangler you will
get caught by me
sounds like someone's really trying to
convince us that he's not the screen
Strangler to my chickens I'm the
Scranton Strangler
angler they trapped him in his house and
then photographing them is believed to
be inside police have now surrounded the
apartment complex
did you do that thing where they play
the really good music to get him to come
out I shouldn't televise any of this
just encourages copycats
and copies why
cats into this
well this is interesting
to work these standoffs can last a long
time what if it's another wake up
pronounce wacko some events are so
newsworthy so historic that you have to
stop everything to watch balloon boy
Michael Jackson's funeral
uh things that if you didn't see them
Live you wouldn't really care that you
didn't see them at all
coming to you from the corner of
Columbia Street in Washington
but he's wishing he had a hybrid right
60 miles to the gallon in the city no I
bet he's wishing he was strangling
something okay that's our street that's
our street he's going down our street
everybody
it's gone
he went right by
e you missed it you missed it
Grandpa where were you the day the
Scranton Strangler was caught well
I was there kiddo I was there
and I'll tell you what
you go sell these
and buy yourself a nice spaceship
last item on the agenda Toby would like
to make an announcement
hi guys hi I just wanted to let you know
that I'll be taking a leave of absence
starting next week oh because you've
been on the lamb because the boring
police have been after you and they
finally caught up with you no the
opposite I was actually selected to be a
juror on a very high profile case yes
the case of the horrible red-headed Sad
Sack and the verdict it was Toby and the
sentence death death to Toby that's the
Toby oh that's hurtful talk we've talked
about that
you leave these huge pauses in your
sentences what do you expect me to do
what's the case Toby well I really can't
talk about it but it's a very high
profile game there's a criminal yes have
we heard of it I don't know is it the
middle school teacher who tried to turn
her foreign exchange student into a sex
slave come on was it the post office guy
rubbed his penis all over the mail guys
it's a really big deal he's rubbing his
neck he's rubbing his neck he's rubbing
his neck he's Grand Strangler oh okay
neither confirm nor deny this let's just
say I'll be up to my neck in jury duty
every day millions of Americans suffer
from extreme repulsiveness someone in
our midst is bringing that problem to
light
Toby flanderson please come up here and
accept the extreme repulsiveness award
oh that's so mean
you gotta play along man
here he comes all right you deserved it
I really disagree with this
I think it's kind of hateful although I
am a little happy right now to have a
platform to talk about the outcome of a
case that I was recently a juror on the
Scranton Strangler a man's being put to
death I was part of the verdict and I'm
not so sure he's guilty anymore
those figures I gave you
false
we had a fight
and I acted vindictively
so you set him up
yes he's innocent
knew it
knew it from the beginning this was a
possibility
I don't know what I just did this now
[Music]
a few years ago
when I was on the jury this Grand strike
sure
I saw it might have been set up but I
felt pressured to convict it's got to be
tough tough I put an innocent man on
death row do you know who's not going to
get to work on some exciting new startup
this year George Howard scope
aka the uh alleged Scranton Strangler
because he's in prison for something he
may not have done I'm sorry the uh the
Scranton who
scream Strangler George Howard Scott
haven't I told you about the jury I was
on a couple years ago
oh what happened I mean if you can talk
about it obviously because if you can't
I mean I I I I could I could talk about
it
see you next Christmas sure I have a
seat I would start at the beginning but
I think I need to go farther back
party's starting
yeah so anyway the entire jerk wants me
to vote guilty but that night I did a
little research on my own and forget
everything you thought you knew about
fingerprint hey Nelly
hmm
I am so sick of February
it's the shortest month but it sure
doesn't feel that way
we should catch up
um
you know I've been going over my notes
from the trials
a few minor points no
Toby you cannot keep blathering on about
this Scranton Strangler do something
about it get it out your system whatever
it takes I've been drafting a letter for
two years then what another year picking
out a stamp another six months before
you decide to lick it just
I don't want to hear it
probably best to use his real name
rather than Strangler don't use his real
name
George Howard scub
it's a devil man
anyway just wanted to say I'm doing it
I'm gone
he's doing it
hi my Toby flanderson here to see George
Howard scub this is the prison
uh I am not going in there with
expectations per se
I will meet George Howard skub I will
tell him that I believe he is innocent
I would understand he felt motivated to
hug me
I would understand if a friendship began
how did how did Bogart put it I think
this is a star to my first friendship
well the good news is no more girls
conscience at least you know he is a
Strangler
the proof is in the grip
did they say when the vocal cords would
heal
one week
okay
two weeks
okay
you offered your neck in search of the
truth
the proud neck of Justice isn't that the
expression yeah well anyway it was it
was very brave
it really was quite Brave
foreign